we work so hard
to get through you to break through
right you're just trying
every step of the way to write the
screenplays to work with the actors and
then finally someone gives you a shot
and then they bam they shut the door on
your face
it felt like well then what's the point
for any new filmmakers watching can you
take us through the process of making a
film all the way from getting financing
to getting
cast attached below the line people
working all the way yeah
if we're talking about making a speci
like a movie specifically that's what
you mean like actually yeah so
um the general process of making the
movie is you know of course it starts
with a script gotta get a script from
somewhere
um
hopefully fine financing
in some way shape or form but whether
that's an investor or credit cards or
something
usually at that point then you find
casting then it becomes
you know
putting your crew together
probably starting with someone like a
cinematographer
deciding to look the props you move into
production
and you're doing that whole scene and
then then it's post on the end of it
that's the general building blocks which
are
probably fairly obvious
the trick is how do you do i mean how do
you if you're if you've never done it
like how do you even
move that ball down the field at all um
that's usually the big question how do i
make a movie how do you get
in the world you do it
i've done three features to this point
and each one of them came about in
different ways
the first one so
actually the first one i ever tried to
make i
i did everything you were supposed to do
i read all the books i read rebel
without a crew i did i read you know all
the books that all the filmmakers read
about independent film and whatever
i wrote a script
my mom told me it was really great
and
all my friends told me how great it was
i found an investor a guy who helped me
with a
business plan but he was only willing to
invest
in the trailer
he didn't have enough money to actually
fund the whole film but he knew business
cool
that's something i lack
so we
wrote we did a killer trailer
we set out to raise money
everybody told me you have never made a
feature
so how
and i was trying to raise like a million
bucks i think i was sorry budget
every investor said this is a high risk
investment
and you've never made a movie so how am
i
how do i know i'm ever going to see it
again and how do i know you know what
you're doing
i heard that over and over and over
again for several years before i finally
gave up it was so demoralizing because
actually the trailer we made was good we
thought for sure people would be into it
didn't work didn't work at all
it was not what the books told me that
would happen it was not
it was very frustrating so here i am
back square one
i got this cool movie trailer yay
for a film that doesn't exist
okay so i had to
go back to the drawing board and go all
right so then how do i make a movie how
do i get this thing made so i
wrote a different script
and i wrote this script
based on things that i knew i had access
to so
i shoot a lot of underwater stuff all
right i can i can maybe add some of that
i wouldn't recommend that
an independent feature film
i did it anyway um wrote this little
murder mystery thing
i set out to raise
forty thousand dollars forty thousand uh
you know i was thinking before i
i thought to myself
i've shot a lot on my camera you know
i've shot i have a lot of experience
behind the camera
i had tried to teach myself as much as i
could about filmmaking i had worked with
another director a whole bunch and he
showed me how
five c stands and a couple of flags and
a little light kit can really do a lot
for you so i'm like and i learned a lot
from him he taught me all this great
stuff so i bought i literally bought
five c stands handful of flags had a
light kit
that's it that's all i had
doorway dolly little bit of track and
okay i can i can make a movie with just
these few elements i'll cast my friends
as the actors
wanna raise 40 grand
i couldn't raise 40 grand i raised 12.
and you know all the people that threw
in was fantastic they were all good
friends of mine but that still left me
in this place of like man how am i
supposed to pull this off without
anything
i decided well i'm gonna take that money
and use it for catering
and for the couple of rentals that i
need and i'm gonna do it anyway
so i
sat out and shot for
five straight weeks
um i shot it during this is this is
really helpful
the people i cast
the first one was an actor who was in
acting school he was on his christmas
break for a month
so he was actually home for a month that
i could grab him for
that was very helpful um
i did not break the shoot up into tiny
pieces like a lot of people do work
because that gets really dangerous
because your actors someone's going to
get married someone's going to get a
haircut
you know
trying to coordinate people for months
and months and months on end is gets
increasingly difficult to do
so i tried to shoot it all in one block
just to get it knocked out and get it
out of the way
so
over christmas time was a great time
work is slow gear is available sometimes
crew is available that made everything
exponentially easier
um
i paid everybody with food
had a friend do the k we came up with
this little and i and by the way
everything we had a crew of five
every all the lighting fit in my suv
and
the i had this little tupperware
container
with um
you know napkins forks and knives salt
and pepper things like that the k this
friend of mine was kind of helping us
cater and she would fill that up and had
all the crafty in it and i could just
pull it out and wheel it to set and she
would bring like a casserole or
something every morning it was a great
little system
she wasn't there all day but it was
something so that the crew was taken
care of and uh i planned like i've never
planned before like i i went and looked
at each location i measured each room to
make sure that the
because i wanted to know if i want to do
a doorway dolly shot through this little
doorway is it even wide enough for me to
do that so i measured it to make sure it
was right and then pre-planned out where
all my shots would be so that i could be
a military operation in every single
location because i did not have the
money to to be able to do extra reshoots
and things like that
so i had this giant three-ring binder
like this that with every little detail
every scene which scene came before
which scene came after so that i could
meet because i didn't have a scripty i
had myself
i was dp
i had three film students
and i had a art department person and a
stunt coordinator like those were that
was it that's all i had
so i needed to be able to create a
system to where i could do it all myself
um
and i did it i pulled it off
now i will say it was one of the most
exhausting experiences of my life
um
it i actually put myself in the hospital
from exhaustion i ended up passing out
in the shower
um but i did it i got it done and
sometimes making your first feature
will take that
to you'll have you may hopefully not you
may have to push yourself further than
you ever thought possible but if you
want it this might be what you have to
do push yourself so much further than
you thought and it wasn't like i had
this great day job gig where i could
afford to take all this time off i
couldn't i was living on credit cards
and i had to push and push and push now
here's the thing
that film
it's you can watch it if you want
it's a 12 000 movie
it's never going to be
it it's a 12 it looks like a and sounds
like a 12 000 movie and it's not
anything great you can it's on amazon
it's called the human trace you can
watch it if you want
watch it
only to inspire you to make something
better
um
i would also tell you at the same time
go watch christopher nolan's following
it was shot for like six grand so
but
because christopher nolan made following
he got to make memento
right sometimes it takes that first one
to get you out the door and if no one is
giving you a shot you're just gonna have
to figure out how to give it to yourself
that's what i had to do and it took
everything i had to make it happen but i
will tell you that after you know 25
years later it is
my most proudest accomplishment because
i did it on my own and i did it and i
made it happen
you won a couple awards did okay it
wasn't ever sold for a lot of money it
didn't do
you know we're all hoping we're all
hoping that when we do it that that's
going to be the thing that opens the
door
don't count on that it probably
won't
hey if it happens for you that's
fantastic but
be careful what how you pin your hopes
on on that one project and i learned
that in the biggest way on film number
two
so
so film number one was done
the true indie filmmaker way which was
blood sweat and tears
doing everything yourself you know
all of that
um even to the point
we recorded like all the underwater
sounds by taking a microphone and
putting a condom around it and dipping
it in the swimming pool and then making
underwater sounds and did all the sound
design like that like it was it was
interesting safe recording that that's
right no one got pregnant
uh
so
that's one way that you can do it and i
will say that the process of that now
the film itself did not open doors
however
from that point forward i could tell
people that i made a movie
they're not going to watch this movie
that doesn't matter i could tell people
that i made the movie that
did help
when it came to the second one
because i was able to tell people i've
done this before i've been through this
mill before i know how to make a
two-hour story and make it hold together
the second film was done
was paid for by a large organization
that they wanted to dramatize a book
so this is an interesting now this is
another way you can make films happen
and i've seen people do this because
they will take a story and wrap it
around a cause
if you can attach your story
to say a book like in the case of this
it was a book they wanted to dramatize
or you could come up with a cause say
i don't know
voting rights or
ending childhood hunger
right
there are organizations that really
you know they're champions of this and
and massive organizations that are
around it fight this kind of thing and
you can get them to partner with you
you will also have a built-in audience
it's a great way to get a film going if
if if your film has some sort of bent
like that it'll give you a platform
access to investors and things like that
cool that's fantastic and also it feels
good when you get out of bed in the
morning because you're making a film
that's actually
doing good like this so my next film was
like that
what that means is that means two things
i'm working for a client that's
different than your own little film
this is gonna be more like what it was
like working in a studio and i'm also
making a film based on pre-existing
material so i'm adapting a book
for a client so that means that i have
to work with a committee of people who
are dictating the story and they're
telling me
things they want in it certain agendas
that they have
that is a
that is what you will run into when you
do a film for an organization this is
it's not necessarily a bad thing it can
be a very
collaborative feeling in this case it
was a very positive creative experience
uh
the
the executive producer and myself are
very good friends to this day we're
still working together
um
we made this film it's called the record
keeper it it was a wonderful experience
to make it's a steampunk
sci-fi thriller about angels and all
that it was super super fun
but
the organization decided at the end of
it not to release it and it's a whole
long sort of story as to why but
this taught me lessons over two which is
when you tie your hopes
to what your project can do or will do
it's a dangerous place to be it's it's
some people refer to that as living in
the future
you are
i i wish i could remember which sports
team this was but i know there's a
famous story about a football team that
was
that it was playing this game and this
one team thought they had won it
and i think there was an interception or
a tackle or something and
team a
ah that's it we won the game and the
fans started flooding the the stadium
and things like that but the play wasn't
over
and the other team somehow grabbed the
ball picked it up and run it to the
other end zone
and it was discovered somehow in this
crazy celebration that they actually
lost
viewers may remember what this story is
i can't quite remember what it is off
the top of my head but that this is
actually something that happened this is
an example of a team that got so focused
on
the future
of winning x going to film festival
winning winning sundance that they
completely lost sight of where they
actually were and that was a very
devastating lesson for me to learn
which was we made this film we were
winning awards people were so excited we
were on set you could feel the magic in
the air as we were creating it we're
working with actors the story was really
cool
we felt like we were on this launching
pad
and all of a sudden we go launching into
the stratosphere and the organization
says no
and i took a tumble
off of that into a very dark place to
the point where i almost gave up making
films it was so hard
because
you we work so hard
to get through you to break through
right you're just trying
every step of the way to write the
screenplays to work with the actors and
then finally someone gives you a shot
and then they bam they shut the door on
your face
it felt like well then what's the point
you know it just it i seriously
thought about
my wife and i talked at length about
maybe we should just go teach english
in korea or something and just give up
uh
it was because
i was pinning my hopes
on what it i thought it was going to do
up here uh and i lost sight of where the
reality of where it actually was
realizing this is a very real
possibility this the signs were there
going along that this could happen but i
just didn't want to see it i just
believed that it would do better than
that
so
i recovered from that whole experience
which took some time
took a lot of
licking of the wounds
and
eventually down the line i got back on
my feet
i ended up at this
fourth time i worked i did i ended up
getting a job it was a way that i i i
got to la and this is something very
interesting because i feel like the
second film that i did if i had lived in
la things would have turned out
differently because my friend's circle
would have been different
well i was living in another city
and the people that i was surrounded by
and people making movies
the artists involved
were just
from that city if i had been in la
making this with la people i think other
it would have
been higher exposure i think the results
would have been different
that's as a side note
so after all this went down it was also
financially devastating so i had to find
a way to get to la after all of this
after this huge wound and
and
all right now i need i need to get down
there and try to figure out a way to
make this happen
so i end up taking a full-time job which
was very
that you know after going whoop i want
to be i'm going to be famous
i'm going to work a full-time job at a
job i hate
i'm the world's worst person right so
boom so i'm in this full-time job but
but while i was in this job
first of all i gave myself a time limit
i'm not i'm only going to be here for a
year this is just to get me to la so i i
did that and while i was in the job
i thought okay i need to get film number
three off the ground i can't let this
second experience be the death of me i
can't let that be the defining moment of
my life
so i went to the austin film festival
and i
met dwayne warrell there
and we connected and
i followed up with him
this is the traditional way how movies
are supposed to be made right so
we get back to la we became fast friends
he sends me the script i couldn't put it
down i loved the script so much i asked
him if it was okay
if i pitched it around
he said yes
i went to another film festival
connected with these other group of
producers came back pissed pasted to
them they said that's great that's a
green light now this is the traditional
way of how you want it to happen in
hollywood right so these are three
different possible ways of how films
get made
is any of them right or wrong absolutely
not
but it's just a way of demonstrating and
how this actually happens
the third way i will say is has been the
most interesting because i'm working for
a production house who's done multiple
films there's a great comfort in that
because they have had things distributed
way more than i have
they have done they they understand the
ins and outs of the other side of the
business that i'm not as familiar with
um that's fantastic there's also a great
because i'm in la i have a great network
of filmmakers
to choose from to help me
make this thing that's also a huge asset
it's given us access to film festivals
that i didn't have before so
there's enormous value in going after a
film like that in that way now
the film is about to release at the time
of this recording so we will see how
this particular process goes but um
you know
so how is a film made it's it's in any
way that you possibly can
it's you you
i had to put myself in the hospital make
the first one i had to take a job i
hated for the third
and all of them were worth it
because
once you're there and you're doing it
it is the the dream that we've all
striven for
it's real
it's magic it's it's
fantastic it's the best job in the world
you